olá galera que assistiu canal do bom com
vocês pois um dia desses eu dei boa
noite pessoal no facebook eu lembrei de
uma coisa muito antiga que foi à tv
cruzeiro e aí eu tinha postado até boa
noite pessoal crush crush crush tchau e
aí o pessoal começou a falar nossa
desenterrou essa antiga e tal eu comecei
a lembrar a infância naquele momento a
minha infância foi muito boa graças a
deus eu tive uma infância bem saudável
era daquele menino que brincava com o pé
no chão num carro tampa do dele jogando
bola nas calçadas com meus colegas único
problema na minha infância que eu sempre
queria ser o paulo a rio vermelho mas
meus amigos nunca deixava o seu carro
vermelho época eu era o mais pequeno
mais branquelo mais mais de [ __ ] e
dava um ódio e quinta com tom de
brincadeira que tinha quando era pequeno
era café com leite todo mundo correr
para brincar de pega-pega e tal corretor
orgulhar como disse collado e eu lá
parar no meio porque ninguém me pegar o
cara o café com leite café com leite era
o bullying das brincadeiras diga não ao
café com leite café com leite é gostoso
odiava os e café com leite e gostei que
você também haviam chegado século está a
chegar
quando era pequena coisa eu gostava
muito de fazer também era balançar a
rede brincar de rodeio na equipe e
também quando rodei na redefarma rede um
certo no meio da rede outro fica lá nos
põe da repúblico chapa poderá ser o
autor de tá pulando a única que eu não
gostava de brincar e hugo henrique era
porque eu sempre era que sentava no meio
não tinha força para puxar ninguém e o
meu pink a puxar os põe da rede anos se
para mais usado e saturna do que
qualquer outra criança da terra eu falar
ele vai pagar em falar tá bom se a
brincadeira dura oito segundos mas não
aguentava 1 por que não eu falava jaime
onde eu vou lá em cima e não podia ver
uma rede que já deitado dentro começa a
balançar o único problema é que eu
gostava de balançar muito saber
balançando e vai ver quem está avançando
rápido a rainha e rainha e rainha e
chegou a hora que você está lá em cima e
começa a perder o chão menino quando
você desta balançada que fica lá em cima
começa a puxar um assim ó se não deu
chances e vão abrir naquele momento ele
já começa a pensar que não vai haver uma
manhã pra você está tudo aquilo que você
conquistou os seus cinco anos de vida
vai se perder e aí a gente desce daquele
só arranca assim que dói na coluna mas
já sabíamos sair tudo bem que quer
quando quer burlar que quer passar
quando você bota balançando quero cuidar
ressecar de bunda assim parece que a
bunda entre 1 5 centímetro acima da
coluna geralmente acontecia isso quero
comigo não chorava porque porque omite
rico quando ele cai e faz questão de
chorar pra mostrar pra mãe que está
precisando de ajuda ai o meu ficar e meu
filme meu deus vai me dar o efeito 3 mãe
ao mini pop domingo e publicar e ele já
não chora que amanda não perceber que
está fazendo aqui na indy deu
agronegócio que eu face ele não resistiu
e chorou
olha carminho menino caiu no caminho
valendo
fica aí ó paí ó vicca néca minha casa
onde dá uma pista aprender nunca mais
vai lançar na rede de uma coisa o diabo
muito quando eu ia dormir era as canções
de ninar porque ela nunca entendi com
essas canções de ninar ver essa canção
de ninar um sonho inalação dos
atualização de deus não é minha grande
felicidade era se eu fosse dormir me
encantasse boi da cara preta meu deus do
céu e diz como é que eu vou dormir
sabendo que embora a cara preta
esperando para me pegar nunca hoje em
dia nem dá pra cantar né boi da cara
preta racismo falar boi da cara preta
tem cantar boi boi boi boi da cara afro
descendente disse que não tem mais nem
dente mas agora pior canção de ninar pra
mim já inventada na terra foi 5 patinhos
meu deus do céu que a música não é deus
não vai eu estava lá até feliz estava
armado assim pra dormir também chegava a
5 patins foram passe a
lindas montanhas para a brincar com o
grupo
a mãe do qual a e só quatro parques
voltaram de lá o começo até agradável do
tony a voz do estilo da música mas
depois que eu vi que só quatro patinho
voltar o meu deus do céu ficará com
apoio da mãe no coração o pior é que a
história continua além de resgatar com
coisa ruim no meu coração é começar
quatro patins foram meu deus do céu que
não vai votar outro partilhou deram a
mãe dito kuakuakuakua mas só três
patinhos montaram disso eu falei que só
a carteira de spike eu ter no céu perto
do cara e fecha a porta do deixa os
patrimar cão e só dois patinhos votaram
de hila eu falei eu falei vitor conversa
eu sabia que não ia voltar outro partido
não vai no peso sendo vai já com meus
três porquinhos jacundá vovózinha com
meu 34 vocês dá voltas jumento só um
patinho voltou de lá meu deus do céu
como o roto parte 1 um patinho foco é o
teto do seu sonho e ainda deixa o pato
irineu do céu samuel nardoni só pode e
nem patim voltou de lá
eu sabia rodrigues eu não quiser dos
patos produto graças a deus que o final
da música os cinco ativos senhoria
lamata sapato tenho certeza mas graças a
deus minha infância foi muito bom eu
gostei muito da minha infância foi bem
saudável acho que na minha época o
máximo de [ __ ] que tinha era só as
cachorras do bonde do tigrão tinha medo
de mim da minha época gostava de brincar
mais de carrinho de rolimã esses coi
hoje em dia hoje em dia eles gostam de
tirar umas fotos no espelho mostrando os
blocos e assim que na verdade de fome
não é da academia as meninas da minha
época pior não dava adeus a dia mesmo a
gente é mais pra brincar de casinha já
botaram piatã nem vagabundo e querem
hoje em dia já vão para a rua de tal que
mostra os peitinhos azeitona site não da
mei palmo de um anão fazendo cosplay
disputa então é isso galera o vídeo de
hoje foi e se você gostou do meu vídeo
por favor adote aos favoritos clique em
adicionar aos favoritos clique em gostei
daquela moral para eu saber que você
passou por aqui que você gostou do meu
vídeo se você está assistindo esse vídeo
no facebook não esqueça de clicar em
curtir compartilha esse vídeo no
facebook isso também ajuda para casa se
você não está inscrito no canal é a
primeira vez que você está assistindo
que dediquei inscrever-se me segue no
twitter me assina no facebook me segue
no instagram fique por dentro de tudo
das fotos que eu tinha do dia a dia
muito obrigado por ter assistido esse
vídeo e tron